one two three four five hello hello
hello okay here we go I want to explain
to you what a recession is I'm doing
this because you're gonna hear this word
a lot lately and depending on how bad it
gets you'll likely feel its effects so
give me 12 minutes to explain recession
plus of course the inevitable time it
takes me to read an ad which is
something I must do in order to pay my
employees and feed my children I'm sure
you can understand I spent four years in
University studying economics preparing
for this very moment so let's go are we
at a turning point headed for a
recession storm clouds of recession
looming and the storm is really coming
inflation at a 40-year high many experts
warn of a possible economic slaughter a
recession is almost inevident we use the
word economy to summarize what is
literally billions of things billions of
people making billions of decisions all
connected to each other and yet the
result of all of these decisions is one
of two things this line either going up
or going down
this all-encompassing number on a graph
is called the gross domestic product GDP
which by the way is kind of the most
undescriptive useless title ever given
to anything GDP is like the receipt of
an economy every single thing that was
made and sold in an economy all added up
into one giant number now there's a very
technical definition that you can go
explore in the sources if you're that
kind of person but for now just imagine
every TV and piano lesson and slice of
pizza and car wash and pair of shoes and
smartphone and video games everything
that the people purchased from the
businesses in your economy in one year
all added up and packed into this one
dot and plopped on a graph
so what we're looking at here is
Britain's GDP in 1990. everything the
economy made and sold to the people
added up to about a trillion pounds that
was their GDP for that year this is this
is the best way that we can summarize
how big an economy is how much it
produces how well it's performing year
after year let's look at a graph this is
what GDP looked like in the old days
like in The Agrarian days you had ups
and downs year by year but really
overall this graph is pretty flat the
economy didn't really have an upward
Trend it wasn't growing that's because
back in the 1300s the economy was a
completely different world than what we
live in today it was pegged to things
like farming which was pegged to things
like weather or plague or War so like
here's the Black Death that killed 40
percent of Europe's population and here
is the great frost a weather event that
ruined a bunch of crops and therefore
made the economy shrink for a year okay
so this is how it was in The Agrarian
days but brace yourself for what happens
next
foreign
this flat line just turned into a steep
cliff and that's because humans started
doing science not just to make
themselves smarter but because they were
incentivized to to make more stuff to
make it more efficiently all of this
happening as humans were developing and
spreading a new set of economic rules
rules that rewarded those who invented
produced and sold stuff that made life
better for both the buyer and the seller
the system was called capitalism
capitalism plus industry was the
cocktail that allowed this to happen by
the way pause the timer for a second
because I need to just say it is painful
how little I am able to include on this
topic go into the sources and just poke
around and you'll see so much good juicy
history on capitalism and the Industrial
Revolution let's move on back to the
timer so every year people could make
more and more stuff they could sell more
stuff and there was more and more GDP
more stuff being made in Seoul in the
economy not just in England which is
this graph we've been using as the
example but eventually in the whole
world
okay but there was a catch to this new
system unlike the old agrarian days
where you could have a graph that kind
of stays generally flat over time this
new system was built off of the idea
that the line kind of has to go up
capitalism works because it incentivizes
people to make products and businesses
that are better and better every year
more and more productive pushing this
line higher and higher every year and
the kind of voodoo magic of capitalism
is if the line doesn't go up
bad things happen
[Music]
okay so here's where it all comes
together we're trying to get to
recession right by the mid-1800s the
capitalist experiment was fully underway
at least in the western world and Japan
the rest of the world was being brutally
exploited to make all this happen anyway
topic of another story see how Europe
stole the world part one and two part
three coming soon the amount of stuff
being made and sold in the economy was
going up more and more every year this
graph is definitely going up but what
about all these soon a mysterious
pattern emerged in this line every few
years the GDP graph would go down for a
little bit the amount of stuff being
made and sold would shrink not
necessarily tied to weather and War and
plague but just because before
eventually recovering and continuing on
its way up and these little dips in the
line we call recession a receding of the
amount of [ __ ] we can make and sell here
is the GDP of the United States since
1948 and here are all the recessions
there have been like 12 and mean we just
got out of one of these we had a very
short but dramatic recession thanks to
covet 19. but the last long recession
was back here the financial crisis
around 2008 the one that you probably
think of when you hear the word
recession subprime derivative the
subprime mortgage meltdown a housing
okay wait wait but why does the graph go
down in the first place like what makes
it go down you can't answer that by
looking at just this big line you have
to zoom into one of these dots and see
what has to happen to create this number
at the very heart of the capitalist
economy you have two major players
you've got people and businesses or as
economists like to call it households
and firms in this case let's just say
the entire economy of your country is
actually the size of your neighborhood
and you're going to your local bakery an
important business in your neighborhood
economy you and your neighbors show up
to this Bakery and you pay three dollars
for a loaf of bread the bakery is a
business that uses that money to pay its
workers but these workers aren't like
some special class of people they're
just other people in the economy who
also are going to go spend money too the
bakery also has to pay rent to a
landlord who's also just another person
in the neighborhood so those people then
go off with their new money that they
just got paid and they spend on other
businesses who also have workers to pay
and rent to pay and suddenly your money
is Flowing to all the people who work in
the economy and everyone's feeling good
about it they have jobs they have a
solid income they can buy cool stuff the
bakery and other neighborhood businesses
feel this demand and they go we need to
hire more people so we can make more
bread and lucky for them there are
investors and the investors are stoked
on all of this demand so they start
investing in the bakery and all the
other businesses giving them money to
hire more people to make more bread more
buying more jobs more stuff being added
to the total the GDP is going up the
economy is growing
okay but what happens when some outside
force comes in to disrupt all these Good
Vibes it all starts when you show up to
your bakery one day and you notice that
something changed suddenly the price of
a loaf of bread is actually four dollars
and the baker's like sorry dude the
price of flour has gone up you know
inflation Supply chains whatever they
say something but the point is what it
does to you suddenly you're feeling like
oh maybe I can't afford this bread or
even if you can you see that something's
up or maybe you hear that the interest
rate is going up something that we're
hearing about a lot lately and so now
you're thinking oh maybe I shouldn't
spend money on expensive artisan bread
but save that money and I can actually
get a good return if you're an investor
the higher interest rates kind of
freaking you out because now it's more
expensive to borrow money you think
twice before investing in the bakery
another option is that you're hearing
rumors about a coming economic downturn
because of some War somewhere and you
judge that it would be wise to save your
dollars instead of spend on expensive
artisan bread or whatever Meanwhile your
neighbors are seen and feeling the same
things and they decide that this bread
is a little bit too expensive for them
and they'll just make bread at home less
bread is demanded from the bakery AKA
There's A disruption in your local bread
Market AKA there's a mismatch between
bread demanded and bread supplied the
bakery hired too many workers during the
good times they now don't have the
revenue to pay them all so they have to
lay some of them off or cut their pay
unemployment is now going up I lost my
job today says your sad looking neighbor
one evening which kind of freaks you out
even more maybe you should be more
careful about your spending and now it's
starting to spread what was just a
decision to not buy bread anymore means
that many employees in the neighborhood
won't get paid and now they can't go out
and spend money which means that other
businesses have less Revenue to pay
their employees and now more people are
hearing about this and deciding maybe
they don't want to be spending and
suddenly there are fewer and fewer
transactions less lending and investment
and now this economy that was once
buzzing with activity is experiencing a
domino effect less stuff is being made
less stuff is being bought your
neighborhood economy is literally
shrinking it's making less stuff your
GDP is lower than it was the year before
your neighborhood is in recession
the point I want to make here is that
this is the result of loads and loads of
people making a bunch of micro decisions
on whether or not to spend their money
and because of the system we're in these
decisions have a massive chain reaction
that affects everyone who participates
in the economy meaning everyone that's
the blessing and the curse of capitalism
okay let's just pull ourselves out of
the analogy with all the pretty
animation and talk about the real world
for a second you're probably wondering
are we in a recession right now are
people spending less money so that the
economy makes less stuff is GDP doing
this I mean maybe
we don't know yet and especially with
this one it's kind of a weird one it's
hard to tell we're getting contradictory
signals from the economy here in the
United States we had two quarters in a
row which is like six months of a
shrinking GDP and this for a lot of
analysts is the definition of a
recession two quarters in a row of
shrinkage we're in a recession but then
just a few weeks ago the news came out
that the third quarter of 2022 the
economy grew again I mean it was by less
than one percent but it grew so that's
not a recession yet plus during a
recession the number of unemployed
people spikes but check out where the
unemployment rate is right now it's nice
and low that's not recession so the
signals are contradictory by the way if
you want a deeper dive into how
recessions are officially classified and
declared and by whom check the sources
in the description there's a whole super
deep dive into that most of you would be
like snoozing after two seconds if I
went into it what we do know is that
people are a little bit freaked out to
be more cautious about their spending
and that's because of a cocktail of
causes that you've heard about in the
news covid-19 giving way to Energy
prices and supply chain disruptions and
this war in Ukraine the result is less
of this and more of this and that's
because hundreds of millions of people
are making hundreds of millions of
little micro decisions every day to
spend less money in an economy that only
works if everyone spends more money and
pushes businesses to make more stuff and
that's the point I want to make here the
big takeaway we talk about the economy
like it's some kind of science I mean I
have a degree in economics a social
science we look at graphs we do calculus
and we feel like we're scientists and in
a big sense we are but what this graph
hides is that what we're dealing with
here are people people who make
decisions based on how they feel and
that's really hard to predict and
control we do it see the inflation video
for how the FED is like a puppet master
we do it but it's really hard to control
and predict so a recession is almost
certainly coming you may be watching
this in like nine months and the
recession is here I don't know the fact
is by looking at this line find what we
can say is that a recession is natural
and normal it is a part of our modern
economic system it will likely come and
then go people will lose jobs businesses
will close and at some point for a
million tiny little reasons things like
policy and just general feelings in a
bunch of people's guts this graph will
stop going down and it will start going
up again that we can be sure
do you know what else we can be sure of
I'm going to keep making videos and in
fact I have just made one of the most
ambitious videos in my entire life it is
about Swiss bunkers
there are bunkers everywhere in this
country the result is this video
really proud of that publishes next week
here on the channel
[Music]
but I actually published it early it's
available right now you can go watch it
literally like right now
if you go to nebula
they turned their mountains into a
literal giant Fortress Yes you heard me
right they turned their mountains into a
fortress nebula is a platform where I'm
going to start publishing my videos a
week early you can go watch them before
anyone else does with no ads and no
interruptions at all this is not a rock
this is a door if you like my videos
you're gonna like the stuff that's on
nebula like this hour and a half long
documentary on the Colorado River by
Wendover Productions it's insanely well
produced real life lore a YouTuber I
deeply respect has a modern conflict
series that is only available on nebula
you can't get it anywhere else in
addition to tons more smart creators it
seriously seems to good to be true so
how much is this going to cost you
that's what you're all asking if you're
going through the front door just like
go to nebula and sign up it's five bucks
a month or 50 a year but there's a hack
for this that makes it way cheap like
ridiculously cheaper like less than a
dollar a month click the link in my
description and we'll take you to
curiosity stream curiosity stream is a
partner of nebula and they have this
bundle deal right now where if you
Center for curiosity stream and you use
my code Johnny Harris make sure to use
the code to support my channel choose
literally the cheapest plan it is less
than a dollar a month if you do the
annual thing it doesn't say it here like
it literally doesn't say it anywhere but
if you do this plan you enter my code
when you're checking out you will get an
email from nebula that says your nebula
account has been activated create a
password and now you get to watch my
videos a week early ad free and tons of
other amazing ad-free content a lot of
it exclusive to nebula doesn't exist
anywhere else curiosity stream is full
of its own amazing repository of
documentaries but I'm telling you how to
get into nebula for a dollar a month so
you can watch my videos a week early
more than any other AD read I have ever
done I can say without a doubt that
clicking that link and using that code
Johnny Harris helps support this Channel
and it also helps support independent
YouTubers who are trying to make really
good stuff if enough people sign up for
nebula using my link they are going to
help support a big ambitious documentary
project I want to work on it's a
documentary project I can't really
publish here on YouTube because I have
to play by sort of the ad friendly
guidelines I have to play the attention
economy game I love that that's fine but
nebula wants to support me making more
and more ambitious stuff you signing up
gets you access to all this stuff but
also helps support us make great stuff
so anyway literally just choose any
curiosity stream plan and use my code
and that's it
it's late it's getting dark out there
um hope everyone's having a good winter
and uh I'm tired it's a Friday today
you're probably watching this on some
other day but I'm gonna go home and
take a nap
[Music]